-Welcome back, everybody!
We're hanging out
with Will Ferrell and Paul Rudd,
right here on Thanksgiving!
[ Cheers and applause ]
On Thanksgiving, thank you
so much for being here.
I want to talk about
"The Shrink Next Door."
By the way, it's fascinating.
I love it.
It's funny, it's dark,
it's real.
It's based on a true --
well, it's not real --
you're acting in it.
-Right.
-But it's based on a real thing
and real guys.
-Yeah.
-And a real situation.
-Real starry of Marty Markowitz,
who decided to try therapy
for the first time in his life,
had some issues,
and 27 years later,
woke up and realized
that the therapist,
played by Paul,
had forced him
to kind of divorce himself
from his entire family,
his business, his every --
and it was just kind of
like he'd fallen into a cult.
-It's a crazy story.
How did you hear about this?
-It was a podcast.
There was a really popular
podcast of the same name,
and I think, when it came out,
I was listening it to it,
Will was listening to it.
-Did you get to meet the guy?
-We did.
-Yeah.
-We spent a whole day with him.
Hung out at his --
Had this Hamptons house,
throw all these parties at,
that the doctor
took over the house
as if it was his own,
and he lived there
as a groundskeeper.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Each story gets more bizarre
as they go along.
-Did you ask him, like --
I don't know
even what to ask him.
Like, why would you --
-Yeah, we kind of --
We're like,
"How did this happen?"
And he's like, "Well..."
It was like, "Yeah,
death by a thousand cuts."
Just over time,
he just didn't realize
till he woke up
kind of too late.
-Wow. It's just unbelievable.
But you both do
a fantastic job together.
Is it hard to do dramatic scenes
with each other?
Because you've been
in "Anchorman."
"Anchorman 2," right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys work
very well together.
-I think that --
I think we liked it.
-Yeah.
-And we were kind of
goofing around
when we were setting up
for shots and things like that.
-When you're off-screen.
-Yeah, but I think we both liked
the idea of playing something
that people might not --
-We already had a shorthand
with each other
and, yeah, made it easy.
-i appreciate you
being on the show tonight.
Not only is it Thanksgiving,
but we had a talent night here,
and we had a young man
came out earlier
sing "Tiny Dancer" Elton John.
-We heard about that.
-He was great,
and people really liked him,
but he got heckled
by two people in the audience.
-Oh, did he?
-You filmed the people heckling?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there's thousands of
cameras the future,
so basically right now
we're living in an Oculus.
I don't even know if you're here
or if you're augmented reality.
-Right, right, right.
-You know, I don't know...
[ Laughter ]
-So, that was --
-Those were real.
-Unfortunately, but they
couldn't have been.
I didn't know at the time.
-Please don't eat that berry.
Paul, stop!
Paul, seriously, stop!
I have no idea
what those things are.
I don't know if they're real.
-They're Styrofoam.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-But they're not bad.
-They're not bad.
-So, you let the show --
you let the hecklers
go on and on and on?
You didn't kick them out?
-You know, it's funny,
I was in hair and makeup.
-Oh, you weren't here.
-No, I didn't see it.
I was backstage
doing hair and makeup.
I do it for other --
for different people.
And I do hair and makeup
[ Laughter ]
And it was fun.
And I just -- you know?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, yeah, I was
just kind of doing that.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh...
There you go.
-Maybe it got better.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's still not good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Will Ferrell
and Paul Rudd
in "The Shrink Next Door."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do we want people
to come to our parties
and enjoy themselves,
or do you want them
to feel uncomfortable?
-No, I want them
to enjoy themselves.
-Do you want to invite people
to take advantage of you?
-Hmm?
-Like Debbie did?
Like Phyllis did?
Kathy, to a certain extent?
-No, of course not.
-I didn't think so.
You know
I'm doing this for you.
To protect you.
We don't care, but
we're looking out for you.
-I know, I know.
-So just try not to say
those kind of things, okay?
-Okay.
-That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Will Ferrell, Paul Rudd,
everybody!
New episode of
"The Shrink Next Door"
released Fridays
on Apple TV+.